hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the key themes and you might even
say arguments that we see Marcus
Aurelius making to himself and you know
because we have access to it to us
readers in his meditations in book after
book after book is this
possibility of things for the entire
universe being one way or being another
and the way that he frames it is largely
in terms of stoic providential ordering
of things where there is a you could say
greater meaning and connection and
intelligence to the universe or its
Epicurean atoms sometimes he uses the
word elements as well but typically he's
saying atoms and what do we mean by this
because we may say well you know today
we actually do believe in atoms so if
you buy into the Epicurean point of view
the universe is rather random there's no
greater plan there's no purpose behind
things it's just atoms falling in the
void and every once in a while swerving
the epicureans do have a little bit of a
trouble explaining human choice and free
will but you know know both sides have
ways in which the universe is
fundamentally arranged and Marcus's
answer to this interestingly is not
going to be well if you believe in atoms
then all bets are off you know but if
you believe in Providence then be a good
boy or something like that he actually
counsels and is one of the I think
strong points of his view that we can do
the same thing
regardless of which side we go to so
this first comes up in a book four and
this is in the famous passage about we
can Retreat into ourselves and at a
certain point he says are you
complaining about the things the world
assigns you consider the two options
Providence
right which literally means like
mind-giving thought to things in advance
or atoms atomoy these basic building
blocks and everything else is
essentially just a function of how atoms
are put together and how they interact
so he's you know he's saying you know uh
consider these either one is going to
lead you to behaving differently right
than you currently are and then in in
chapter 27 a little bit later in here
he is going to contrast again two
possibilities an ordered world so Cosmos
Cosmos is the word for order Beauty
Arrangement and world
dietitagmano so it is arranged right it
is arranged in the DIA is kind of an
intensive here so in an ordered world or
a mishmash the word that he uses for
that is kukion which is also translated
as mixture in other places so again an
ordered World from the stoic perspective
or just a bunch of random stuff kind of
thrown together and interacting from the
Epicurean perspective and so he says
it's an ordered world or a mishmash but
regardless of which it is it's still an
order it's still a cosmos it's still a
world and so he says can there be order
within you and not in everything else in
things so different so dispersed so
intertwined so notice what he's adding
to the picture here we've got these two
big cosmological alternatives
but then we can think about ourselves
so if everything is just kind of a
mishmash does that mean that there's no
order within ourselves
Marcus says no
and that creates the possibility for us
bringing that order to other things
there's a more intense discussion of
this going on in book six which I think
is a really excellent one he's framing
things in terms of two different
possibilities once again but now he
gives you a number of ways of
characterizing it so it's either a
mixture right interaction
now this interaction interweaving would
be another way of translating it uh
plocaine is to weave together sort of
like what a weaver actually does in
creating fabric so anteplokay things
being woven in relation to each other
and then dispersal uh skedassmos right
when we die our bodies break up into
their constituent parts so it's either
that
or there is a Unity an osis right n hen
means uh one right an order a taxes an
arrangement taxes implies some sort of
intelligent way of putting things
together or design or Providence pero
Noya it's one of these two and again he
says
either one we can do the right thing if
it's the first why should I care about
anything except for the eventual dust to
dust and why would I feel any anxiety
dispersal is certain whatever I do so if
I'm gonna die and my atoms will be
dispersed I don't need to worry about
that right but if the other one is the
case then reverence Serenity faith in
the power responsible two different
Alternatives two different responses
both of which are good for Marcus's
perspective
going on we see this language of atoms
or Providence again coming up in book
Seven in a number of passages so he
talks about death first in chapter 32
very short passage on death if Adam's
dispersed right to spread out all over
the place if Oneness now this is
interesting if Oneness then
quenched this is the word for like
putting out a lamp or candle or fire
spaces right our bodily frame is is
quenched our mind is or change
metastasis the things that are me get
changed into things that are something
else and Marcus actually will talk at
other places about people need to die to
make room for other people in the world
right in uh 50 he's gonna reiterate this
talking about some similar things having
to do with death he says Earth's
Offspring back to Earth but all that's
born of Heaven to Heaven returns again
and he says well it's either that so
that would be like the you know
providential ordering or the cluster of
atoms pulls apart and one way or another
the insensible elements disperse all the
things that are composing me go their
separate ways and it's no longer a you
know me a Unity that is there uh in
um 775 there's there's a longer
discussion there's the very end of uh
book Seven he says this is very
interesting nature now the the we got to
be a little bit careful with the
translation here nature willed the
creation or nature chose the creation of
the world so jormeze right so this is
coming from horme which does mean choice
in stoic
um you know philosophy of action and
ethics but it also means impulse so so
nature itself who says gave impulse
essentially to itself and generated
created a world Coast right so poiesis
is creation production
Cosmo is is Cosmos is World in this case
so nature did this now
how did it do it well this is very
interesting either it did it in what we
could call an orthodox stoic way right
either all that exists follows logically
because it's it's been you know thought
through cut
um
right so uh this is coming from the word
to follow and this is you know two
different uh prepositions cut according
to and then the app here following upon
so when Nature had its big plan it's
paranoia in mind everything follows
along that so that's one possibility
or
nature created the world
but even those things to which the
world's intelligence most directs its
will are completely random right uh and
he actually uses the word hegemonic on
here the the ruling intelligence and he
uses that term horme again all the
things that it chooses are ultimately
random uh logista
so even the most important things are
you could say random but you could also
say not governed by reason not rational
right so either one of these is the case
and then he says this is a source of
Serenity in more situations than one now
why well because of this same logic
either alternative we human beings can
bring our own order we can choose for
ourselves we're not simply because
things are random just random things
are on our own right
in 9 28 he's going to bring this up
again and talk about you know the world
cycles and he says either the world's
intelligence Wills each thing if so
except it's will or an exercise that
will once and for all and everything
else follows as a consequence if so why
worry so these are two different ways of
having uh we could call it a thoughtful
arrangement of things either the world's
intelligence like is still involved in
the process or it just like got
everything kicked off but put the plan
in place so he says one way or another
atoms or Unity if it's God all is well
oh in Greek everything's going just fine
if it's arbitrary or random Or Without a
Cause AK
then you know that's okay too don't you
he says be like that so don't imitate
that literally don't you be random
causeless thoughtless right so either
way we can do quite well
um same thing being said a little bit
later on in uh
10 chapter 10 6 and this is a much
longer quote whether it's atoms or
nature now notice it's nature no matter
what because the atoms are part of
nature what it means when he says nature
is nature in the stoic sense that
involves some sort of planning or
Providence paranoia some sort of unity
right so whether it's atoms or nature he
says the first thing to be said is I'm a
part of this world controlled by Nature
I am a part right secondly that I have a
relationship with other similar parts
and with that in mind I have no right as
a part to complain about what's assigned
to me as as a whole right so he says the
nature of the world is defined by a
second characteristic as well no outside
force can compel it to cause itself harm
so keeping in mind the whole life form a
part of whether it's atoms or nature
I'll accept whatever happens and because
of my relationship to other parts I'm
not going to do self selfish things but
aim to join them to direct every action
towards what benefits us all and avoid
what doesn't if I do that my life should
go smoothly as you could expect a
citizen's life to go so he's saying we
can participate whether it's Adam's or
nature random or you know logical we can
still behave the way that would be
befitting to us finally there's one last
passage that I think is worth bringing
up 11 chapter 18. and this is in the
course of his famous you know nine gifts
from the muses to help you not be such
an angry miserable person and then one
more gift from Apollo in the very first
gift he says start from this
if not atoms
so if it's not totally random then it is
nature then there is some sort of plan
directing everything right
now this is a very interesting term it
doesn't just mean directing Oikos is
household or economy right so everything
is part of one vast household that is
being directed by this you know
providentially ordering intelligence
so he says if that's the case then lower
things exist for the sake of higher ones
or worse things for the sake of better
ones right and the for the sake of is
Hanukkah so you know this nature that we
see in front of us exists for us
rational beings and then he goes on and
he says and higher beings exist or exist
or are on account of each other
right the other person so
whichever we accept
if not atoms then it's nature and then
that tells us again how we ought to
behave but even for Marcus even if it is
just atoms all random no Rhyme or Reason
to anything no directing intelligence
that doesn't prevent us
from behaving well bringing order to
ourselves to our relationships to the
world the little bit of it that we have
some measure of controller participation
within we can still live a good life
whatever the alternatives are so you can
say why is he reminding himself of this
precisely perhaps to avoid falling into
a kind of fatalistic attitude well it's
all random so it doesn't really matter
what I do Marcus is telling us it does
matter and we have
choice and some measure of control over
how it is that we look at things and
what it is we choose to do